[Music]
the local elections were the first real
test of kirsten's leadership
and it wasn't good the tories took
control of another dozen councils
and got an extra 200 councillors elected
so what's gone wrong for the party
is this part of a wider political
realignment or would a new leader do the
trick
i'm joined now by andrea adonis a
minister in tony blair's government
along with paul embery a current labour
member
a lifelong labour member and a former
executive at the fiber grades union
also an unheard columnist paul what's
your diagnosis of what went wrong in
hartley pool
um well what went wrong is that the
labour party
has increasingly over year over recent
years become
a middle-class pressure group and the
the old coalition
on which the party was based and on
which it enjoyed much of its success
um was was hardly poor in hampstead it
was
yes a layer of middle class white collar
uh people who supported labour's ideas
of a more egalitarian
economy um but also the blue collar
working class
base and places lighthearted pool in
provincial and post-industrial britain
just look at the labour party nowadays
and think actually you don't look like
me you don't
sound like me you don't share my
priorities you try to overturn the
referendum result when we've able to
leave
um why shouldn't we vote for you so
there's a huge
disconnect which has been entirely
self-inflicted by the labour party
and paul do you think the choice of
candidate played a role in this because
uh much to be made the fact they were
someone who had supported a second
referendum
i think the the choice of candidate
obviously wasn't ideal
i mean paul williams was an uber
remainer um
and in a constituency that voted 70
percent leave
um and in many of these places by the
way people are still bringing bring in
with anger at the labor party over the
fact that they
tried to overturn their vote and the
problem is labor
wasn't exactly spot for choice this is
the problem for the labour party that
old working class element which was once
the backbone of the party um you know
people had come up through the trade
union movement people had worked in
manual labor
people who were based in blue collar
constituencies and were part of the
labour movement they're just not there
in any
serious number anymore so i would
imagine if labour did want to select a
leave candidate for heart deport
it would have had a pretty hard job to
to find someone that's the problem
so do you think andrew that the choice
of a
remain candidate in a seat that voted 70
for brexit
was a big factor in this or or not no i
don't think it was at all indeed i think
it swings in roundabouts the candidate
paul williams
uh is a local gp and he was in many ways
an extremely attractive candidate
the tory candidate came from yorkshire
and anyone who knows hartley poole and
t-side knows that uh the only thing
worse than having somebody from
hampstead is
somebody from yorkshire so the idea that
the
the candidates the local candidates
played a role
i don't think is correct i think as i
say that the two people on the ballot
paper in hartlepool
were boris johnson and kierstarma and
they went for boris johnson and
the history of elections if you look at
polling
all the way back to the beginning of
polling is that almost without
exception the party that wins elections
is the party that has the more popular
leader
and in the head-to-head on the
leadership stakes at the moment
it's boris johnson not kirsten
paul i think i disagree profoundly with
andrew that this is essentially just
really
a question of leadership this is not a
question of leadership changing the
leader in the labour party at the moment
uh would essentially be reshuffling the
the dechares on the
titanic this is a question about the
labour party's dna
this is a question about the culture
about the structure
of the labour party it runs far wider
than questions of
leadership and party management and the
idea that all we need to do is return to
you know some sort of reheated blarism i
i think that you know for for all that
parts of his essay were right in the new
statesman this week tony blair
showed a bit of humility and i think
andrew needs to show a bit of humility
it was that kind of blair right
embrace of the global market and
everything that went with it you know
the loose immigration policy
it was the the promotion of cosmopolitan
liberalism
um over over everything else which
alienated blue-collar
communities in the first place for all
the good that new labor did it
completely
fail to understand the communitarian
impulse in many
of those communities people's desire for
social solidarity their desire
for stability a sense of belonging the
acute effects that globalization had
in the first uh in the first decade of
this century cannot be
overestimated and what blairism did
effectively is it laid in train what
we're seeing now
in terms of the the work agenda where
the liberal left effectively just
demonized millions of working-class
people as racist and
nativist we saw it in brexit we saw it
well before brexit
and that was that anger was storing up
for years in these communities and i
know it because i lived in one
andrew do you think it's time that you
should show some humility
uh paul mentions that tony blair article
in the new statesman this week where
he says the party has gone too far when
it comes to the so-called woke end
but surely that does link back to the
blair area to a degree
well paul sprayed so many different uh
claims and
allegations it's very hard to get a
handle on it in particular it's almost
impossible
to get a sense of where you would go in
future on what he said because he thinks
the corbyn wasn't the answer
he thinks that blair wasn't the answer
he thinks we've both at the one on the
one hand
been too woke whereas in fact actually
tony if you read his article has a
critique
of the problem of labor being seen to be
extremist
on some of those issues all i would make
is two two observations
uh labour won three elections when tony
blair was leader
and it swept all of the areas we're
talking about it held all
almost all of the seats in the northeast
when he was leader and that includes
in his third election so to blame him
for what happened
15 years later i think it's just
straightforwardly unhistorical and
though
times change approaches don't change
and the big problem that labour has is
it does not have a leadership
that is capable of appealing to the
north and south now of course it's true
that a leader has to have policies and
ideas
this business this idea though that the
policies and ideas of blair were somehow
the destructive of community
and social progress though again is is
completely unhistorical
it was that labour government that
substantially rebuilt the public
services
massive investment in health education
remember tony blair's mantra was
education
education education a huge expansion of
opportunity
the big problem in communities like
hartlepool which i know well
i i i i come off a council estate i've
got a pretty good idea
what uh what working class people think
too is that
though labour did a brilliant job of
rebuilding the public services
what was needed and is needed is a
viable economy
jobs businesses industry in these
communities
and that's particularly true in the
northeast which has had
a really terrible uh 40 years now since
the
decline of the mass industries paul
does some of this come back to brexit
some labour campaigns have said it did
not come up from the doorstep
but clearly it has been perhaps the the
point where
lots of people who felt disillusioned
with labor finally made the jump
the the labour's policy of a second
referendum was electoral suicide
frankly um it was only going to end in
electoral oblivion
if you look at these statistics 50 of
the 54 seats that went from labour to
the tories at the last election
voted brexit the idea that labour was
ever going to get away with saying to
millions of working-class people
um actually we think you got it wrong
we're going to make you go through the
vote again
um was frankly insane uh it certainly
isn't the only factor
as to as to why there's been a huge
disconnect between labour and the
working class but but it was a big one
and i would simply say to andrew look
the statistics show that labour has been
losing the working class since around
about the turn of the century you know
that the c2
des um have been voting for labour less
and less and
labour has become more of a middle-class
party in terms of attracting the
the abc ones um and you know
as as i said the acute effects of
globalization in some of these
communities in terms of rapid
demographic change in terms of
de-industrialization
in terms of people's sense of place and
belonging being violated
cannot be cannot be overestimated and
and you know the truth is now that
people in those communities
look at the labour party uh and i'm a
member of the labour party by the way so
so it pains me to say to say this but
they look at a party
now that is a party effectively for the
professional and managerial classes a
party for student radicals
um a party for twitter a party for
social activists
a party that's rooted in the fashionable
cities in the university towns
and i think that this is potentially a
paradigm shift
you know in 1983 even when labour was
crushed um
at the general election under michael
foote against margaret thatcher
labour managed to retain much of its
working-class base
that isn't happening now i mean this is
this is a serious and seismic shift for
the labour party
and unless something happens quite
urgently which goes
far beyond the question of leadership um
then the party will effectively relegate
itself to a middle-class pressure group
andrew do you think they might just have
to look at the landscape and think that
if there is a realignment of politics
going on their future lies
in commuter towns in the cities and
potentially in tory home counties there
are some encouraging results for the
labour party
when it came to the later results in the
local elections well i actually agree
with paul that the moment labour gives
up being a national party
it uh is heading for oblivion it's
either a national party or it becomes a
small pressure group
i think its history is is is wrong
labour held its working-class vote
through
all of tony blair's three elections and
indeed our problem in the third election
was we had a
loss to the lib dems in the third
election because of iraq
and iraq wasn't an issue with with
working-class voters at all
but on his point about it not being
leadership the truth is like many
political discussions
you can't be sure because we don't know
what the counterfactual would be
labor has not had an effective and
popular leader
since tony blair every leader we've had
since all four leaders we've had since
have been
as the polls show and as all of the
analysis of election shows they have all
been
less popular than their tory counterpart
gordon brown was less popular than david
cameron
ed miliband was less popular than david
cameron theresa may
was more popular amazingly than jeremy
corbyn and
boris johnson ran rings round corbin in
the 2019 election
so my proposition to you which is that
when labor has had
a good effective strong centrist leader
who's able to mobilize north and south
working class and middle class that
that's led to success
is demonstrated by tony blair paul says
it's not the case now all i can say is
since tony blair went
every leader of the labour party has
been weaker
less effective and less nationally
unifying than the conservative leader
so it may not be a bad place to start to
get a popular leader
um andrew i just wondered when you
mentioned obviously the party losing
working-class voters
do you think the brexit position that
both you and tony blair adopted
has helped keep working-class voters on
side
no i don't actually if you look at the
votes and indeed if you look at the
brexit vote half of the brexit vote was
in the
in the home counties it wasn't in
traditional working-class areas at all
the big problem was
that for the last five years labor has
been lead leaderless on the issue of
europe
we had jeremy corbyn leading during the
2016 referendum
who was sitting on the fence essentially
i think he made one speech in the entire
campaign
and then he said he was moderately in
favor of remain but not strongly
so if and of course he then sat on the
fence for the whole of the next four
years
when you've got one party that has a
clear and emphatic
and well-led campaign and you've got
another party that has
a weak flabby position which is
untenable in its own terms because
because corbyn was facing both ways
surprise surprise it's the strong leader
that wins and it's the weak leader that
loses and i'm afraid
are you saying yeah andrew can i just
think i mean are you are you saying that
had labor
um been been more passionate about the
about the second referendum um and less
you know ambivalent
um actually we wouldn't have lost
millions of those working-class votes
that actually the way to have gone would
have
been to be more stridently pro-eu and
more stridently in favor of blocking
the referendum result and actually the
heartless of this world would have
stayed on board with the labour party it
seems to me what you're saying
well again we don't know because there
wasn't a second referendum i think we
can i think we can
i think we can hazard a pretty good
guest at the time show that if there was
a second referendum there would have
been
a majority to stay in the eu so we'd but
because there wasn't the second
referendum we don't know but if you're
asking me do i think we should have had
a second referendum and would the second
referendum have built a new
labour coalition in alliance with the
greens and the lib dems
and indeed the nationalists in favor of
staying in the eu which would have
marginalized the conservatives and the
brexit party
it is my view that's what would have
happened it would also it was
is the point and that builds a new core
vote but unfortunately we had jeremy
corbyn
we didn't have the second referendum
instead we had boris johnson
who got to a second election before a
second referendum and the election was a
choice between
boris johnson and jeremy corbyn as prime
minister and that was
a film that only ever had one ending i'm
afraid it would be
i think it would be an utter betrayal of
the labour party's entire purpose to say
actually what we really need to do
is to build a new coalition around young
people
people in the cities graduates people
who are pro-eu
in alliance with the greens and the lib
dems and that's our new base
actually the reason the labour party was
set up in the first place as you know
was to represent the voiceless in
society the people living in the poorer
parts of our
nation the people in industrial
communities like heartland pool and the
idea that because
we couldn't carry them over the idea of
a second referendum well we should just
write them off and concentrate on a new
base
um i i think really would be a betrayal
of everything we're supposed to stand
for in the movement but that
but you may not be what you said andrew
that would be that would be the logical
conclusion
it's neither what i said nor is it the
conclusion it's my view that if we'd
been more successfully led we would have
been able to build a coalition that
included
the lib dems the greens and uh
the uh working class in communities like
around the demand for a second
referendum
it's because we were badly led that we
were unable to do that and that's the
reason why boris johnson preposterously
is now the champion of the working class
in hartlepool
andrew do you think with hindsight
perhaps the mistake later made was not
to support theresa may's brexit deal
there has been a point made that had
they done so
the tory party would be divided
potentially
imploding and she could have kept on to
some of those voters who
had voted for brexit but also backed
labour the mistake in hindsight was to
elect jeremy corbyn as the labour party
leader in 2015
and then to allow him to fight a second
election in 2019
whenever the the british people were
faced with a choice as who they wanted
as prime minister
and jeremy corbyn was on the ballot
paper they were always going to go for
the conservative even a conservative as
weak as theresa may
at the end of the 2017 election was
significantly more popular than jeremy
corbyn
and boris johnson was head and shoulders
above jeremy corbyn
by the end of the 2019 election both as
a leader but also on economic policy
which is the most important
policy that people fight elections on
where labour's trillion pound
nationalization
program which by the way would have
offered working-class voters in the
north almost nothing
in terms of better public services or
better jobs
that was again always going to end in
disaster it's because labour hasn't been
able to find a good leader since tony
blair that we're in this mess
until we put this right i'm afraid we'll
continue in it
[Music]
you